hey there welcome to selenium web driver
tutorial by simply learn my name is
anaga and today in this video we'll be
talking about the selenium webdriver
basics
what is that you should be expecting
from this video let's see what is
selenium whenever we are learning about
any tool it's good to know a little bit
brief history of it so we will look into
how selenium has evolved over years to
become the most popular web application
automation tool and why use webdriver
and then we will understand what a
selenium driver while we learn this i
will also be touching
upon some drawbacks of manual testing
and how automation helps
and then a deep dive into architecture
of webdriver
as you know every automation tool has
its own advantages and limitations so we
will be understanding the limitations of
selenium webdriver
and how we work around this and then i
will demonstrate the web driver
in action for which i will use a simple
web application use case to automate
so let's get started so before we talk
about selenium let's understand a few
drawbacks of manual testing let's take
an example of a very simple use case
as a user i want to login to my web
application
using username and password a very
simple use case and it's a very common
use case for any kind of web application
you're working so as a tester what do i
do
i need to write multiple test case to
test this use case
so i can use multiple data sets like
valid credentials invalid credentials
null values and so on
to test this particular use case and
then what you do you start executing the
test cases one by one you find bugs then
your developers fixes them
and then you will need to rerun all the
test cases again and again
until all the bugs of for this use case
are fixed and your application is ready
to
ship now look into this now this brings
us to the first merit
demerit of the manual testing which is
what if one has to run test cases with
hundred transactions
and repeat them again and again this is
going to be a very time consuming
process and very boring
also it is more error prone since it's
done manually and human mistakes are
bound to happen
the third challenge is the scope of
manual testing
itself is very limited for example say
regression testing
ideally you would want to run all the
test cases which you have written
but since it's a manual process this is
going to be very tedious to do
and also you would not have all the
luxury of time to execute all test cases
so what do you do you start picking up
those test cases which are very
important
to be run and that way you are kind of
limiting the scope of your testing
also working with large amount of data
manually is going to be impractical what
about performance testing
you want to collect metrics on various
performance measure
as a part of your performance testing
you want to simulate multiple loads on
your application under test
and all these things manually it is very
difficult to perform
and it's not feasible also and to submit
all this creating manual test reports
after running all the tests
who wants to really do that and again
another level of challenge here is say
if you're working on an agile model
where code is being churned out by
developers the testers are building
their test cases
executing them as and when the bills are
available to them
this happens iteratively and hence you
will need to run all those test cases
which have written
multiple times during your development
cycle and doing this manually definitely
is going to be very tedious and boring
and is this
effective of doing it no so what do we
do we automate it
so this tells us why we want to automate
one for faster execution
two to be less error prone three to help
frequent execution of our tests
so there were many tools available in
the market for automation
one such tool was selenium and that
brings us to the slide
advent of selenium so much before
selenium there are various tools in the
market like rft
qtp just to name a few popular ones so
selenium was introduced by a gentleman
called jason huggins
way back in 2004. he was an engineer at
thoughtworks he was kind of working on a
web application which needed frequent
testing and he realized the inefficiency
in doing manual testing of his
application repeatedly
so what he did was he wrote a javascript
program that automatically controlled
the browser actions
and then he named that as javascript
test runner he made this open source
which was later renamed as selenium core
and this is how the selenium came into
existence so with this brief history of
selenium let's understand what the
selenium and what are its main features
selenium is the most popular and widely
used automation tool
for automating web applications it
enables us to test web application on
different kind of process
like internet explorer chrome firefox
safari
opera and so on and also they introduced
support for
edge browser after microsoft introduced
it selenium is a set of tools and
libraries to facilitate automation of
web application it is not a single tool
it has multiple components and
those we will be seeing uh in some time
all these tools
together help us test the web
application so selenium is open source
and it is platform independent this is
the biggest reason why people are
preferring
this tool because it is free of cost qtp
and rft which i just talked about are a
chargeable one selenium scripts
can run on any platform because selenium
is primarily developed in
javascript so it is platform independent
well as you know it's common for manual
testers not to have in-depth programming
background
so selenium has a record and replay back
tool called the selenium ide which can
be used to create a set of actions as a
script
and to replay that script but this is
mainly used for demo purpose
why because selenium is such a powerful
tool that you should be able to take
advantage of all its feature and not
just be with the record and replay tool
right so that way there are a lot of
record and replay tool anyway available
in the market the selenium provides
support for different programming
language java python
c sharp ruby php and so on you can write
your test scripts in any language you
prefer or you like and again as i said
one need not really know in-depth or
advanced knowledge of these
languages you would still be able to
write the selenium scripts with the
basic knowledge of this programming
language
and also selenium supports various
operating systems you can run selenium
test on windows mac
or linux or even say if you have a
ubuntu machine you can always run your
selenium test
on ubuntu machines so of you can run the
test on any platform
of your choice okay so let's go now a
little more deeper into selenium
so i said that selenium is not a single
tool but it is a suite of tools right
so now let's look at what are those
major components which comprises of the
selenium suite
first one is the selenium id so selenium
ide is the most simplest tool in the
whole suite of the selenium it is
nothing but it's an
integrated development environment
earlier this ide
was simply a firefox extension and it
offered a
record and playback functionality it was
a very simple and easy to use
and as i said mainly this is used for
prototyping or for
only the demo purposes right and not
creating automation for your real-time
projects
because you know of its own limitation
of being a simple recorded replay too
however selenium what happened selenium
ide
it died with firefox 55 so that means uh
the support for ide was stopped from
firefox 55 version
but the good news is very recently all
new
brand new selenium ide has been launched
and also what they have done is they
have made this cross browser
that means you can install the extension
on chrome
the id extension on chrome or as an
add-on on firefox so it is supported on
both the browsers firefox and
chrome all right so while we're talking
of this ide let me also
show you uh how the latest id on the
chrome looks
okay for that let me go and launch my
chrome browser
so let me just open a new tab and what
i'll do is i'll search for
selenium id for chrome download then i
go to this website
and then you can see here selenium id
offered by seleniumhq.org so what i
simply need to do is
like you install any extension on your
chrome browsers i just say add to chrome
and this
adds this extension on your chrome
browser
now it is added so selenium ide has been
added to chrome use this extension by
clicking the side screen so can you see
this icon here which is
selenium id that's it so once you have
installed this you are free to start
using the id on this chrome browser
similarly you can do adding of this
add-on which is called as add-on on
firefox so
go to the firefox browser search for the
selenium id and
just install that add-on so let's get
back to our presentation so that's about
the id
so what's our next component our next
component is selenium rc which is
nothing but selenium remote control
selenium rc
is used to write web application test in
different programming
languages it interacts with the browser
with the help of
rc server it has an rc server through
which only it can interact with the web
browser
and how does it communicate it uses a
simple http get and post request
and this is what was called as selenium
1.0 version
but it got deprecated in 2.0 version and
it was completely removed in 3.0 and was
replaced with something called as web
driver so we will be talking in detail
about
why this happened what were the
drawbacks of rc which led to
replacing with the web driver so now
that brings us to third component which
is the selenium
webdriver this is the most important
component it is just a programming
interface to create and execute our test
cases
of course it's a successor of rc because
there were certain drawbacks which i
just mentioned and we will be going in
detail of
what it were so web driver what the
major difference what we see with the
web driver is the architecture of the
web driver is much simpler than rc
for the reason that webdriver interacts
with the browser
directly unlike your rc where it needs
an rca server to interact with the
browser
so this gave a lot of advantage an edge
over
the rc the fourth component selenium
grid
selenium grid is used to run multiple
test scripts on multiple machines
at the same time with selenium driver
you can only do the sequential execution
however in real time environment you
know that there is always a need to run
tests on distributed environment for
example say you have a web application
and say you have automated around
hundreds or thousands of test cases
and you need to run them as a regression
suite and also
one of the ask is that you need to run
this on multiple browsers and multiple
os why since you have automated them
and your application supports multiple
browsers and os
now imagine the time taken to run these
thousand test cases sequentially with
the web driver right it's going to
take quite a bit of time so what you
need is to run this parallel
on multiple machines matrix across the
browsers and operating system
and that is where the grid helps you in
achieving that
so grid has this hub and node concept
and it helps in achieving the parallel
execution which
i just talked about so you can check out
our detailed video on selenium grid on
simplyla all right so now we talked
about the components of the selenium so
let's look at the different
versions it evolved into so when i
talked about
rc i mentioned that this was selenium
one version so now let's understand
how this evolved over years and what it
offers today so when jason huggins
introduced selenium the tool was called
javascript program he called it as
javascript test runner it had one major
issue now that is something called a
same origin policy so what is the same
origin policy
it says that a javascript when executed
in a domain can access web pages
in that domain only and it cannot access
any web pages in another domain
i will repeat it same origin policies
dictates
that a javascript is executed in a
domain
can access web pages in that domain only
and it cannot access web pages in
another domain for example
say every web page in say google.com
domain
like search email drive can be
accessible
but nothing outside of google.com like
say if you want to access a web page and
say amazon or yahoo
is possible to access why because of the
simple reason which is a security
reasons
now to overcome this paul homan created
something called a selenium remote
control server and why did he create
that he
wanted to trick the browser in believing
that the selenium
core through which you're going to run
your scripts and your web
application under test are in the same
domain
with which you are able to achieve run
your test
on your web application without having
to get into this issue of same origin
policy so this is what was a version one
of selenium
and we called it as selenium remote
control and then what happened
in 2007 simon stewart okay he invented
this web driver now why did he invent
this because
the architecture of selenium rc was
little complicated
rc required a separate server to talk to
your browsers
so what he did was he removed the
requirement of having a separate server
in the rc
and this was the selenium 2 version now
since it was a transition
phase both the selenium rc and the web
driver co-existed in selenium 2. while
the web driver was still under
development and then what happened in
3.0 selenium
is the selenium core which is the rc was
completely deprecated and only the web
driver was made available
so in this series of videos we will be
working with selenium 3.0 and now
selenium 4 is already around the corner
so alpha is already released as of the
day when this video was made and i
believe
some of the features what the selenium 4
is going to offer
is they are moving towards w3c web
driver standardization
one and also there is going to be an
improved id the id which i just talked
about that it's a
improved version of the previous id and
then an improved version of selenium
grid also so they might be doing a gui
based grid right so these are some of
the major features
expected in this version why selenium
webdriver so let's look at
what led to replacement of selenium rc
with this webdriver for that first we
need to understand the selenium rc and
its shortcoming
as i said selenium rc is a simple tool
to write tests for web applications
in various supported programming
languages like java python ruby and c
and this is the architecture of the
selenium rc at a very high level first
you need to write test scripts in any of
the supported languages of your church
so if you are more familiar with java
you would be writing your test scripts
all your commands in the java
so before we start writing the test one
of the major requirement
right required for the rc to run is your
rc server
so first you need to start this rc
server before you run even a single line
of code
and this rc server is a separate
application and now what is
the function of this rc server the
selenium server or the rc server
is responsible for receiving cellini's
commands from your test script
it interprets them and then reports the
result
back to your selenium test now what are
the selenius commands
these commands are nothing but the
commands returned
in your test script these are called as
salinis command that is what the
selenium server does
now after the selenium servers function
let's look at how the browser
interaction happens the browser
interaction
happens through this rc server this rc
server
uses a simple http post and get request
to communicate and how does this
communication happen this rc server
acts like a proxy say for example your
test script
asks for launching a browser this
command from your test script
goes to the server and then this rc
server launches the browser
injects its javascript into the browser
once this is done
all the subsequent calls that is all the
subsequent calls is all the rest of the
commands which you have written after
launching the browser
go to this rc server and then to the
actual web server so it routes
all the commands are getting routed
through your rc server to your web
browser upon receiving this instruction
so what does the code do it executes
these commands
as the javascript commands on your
browser so once these are executed
the response from the browser or the
results what you say
are sent back to the rc server and rc
server is responsible for sending it
back to your test
and then the test results are displayed
here now if you see this complete cycle
from starting your command from your
test script talking to the rc server
then rc server talks to the web browser
it injects the javascript here runs your
command
takes back the results sends it to rc
server and then back to this
test script this whole cycle gets
repeated for every command which is
written in your test script
and this is how your test case gets
executed all right
so now everything is fine so great we
are unable to run the scripts we are
able to
launch the browser we are able to
execute all the commands so what was the
problem here why was still rc not good
enough
for the reason why the rc was still not
good enough was
one the architecture of rc is very
complicated
because of that intermediate rc server
to communicate
with the browser so there is no direct
interaction with the browser this rc
server needs to be installed before
running any test scripts that means it
has an additional setup because that is
rc server is a mediator between your
selenium commands and your browser the
execution of the commands takes very
long time it is very slow
why because we saw that every command
written in your test scripts
needs to make a full trip from your test
script to the rc server to the core to
the browser and then back
which makes your overall automation test
execution
very very slow so how the selenium web
driver now overcomes this
this is a simple architecture of
selenium webdriver even in web driver we
have test scripts
we have a web browser and a web server
however
we do not have an additional server for
communication like the rc server which
we saw in the selenium rc
this makes the architecture of web
driver very simple the selenium web
driver that's one of the biggest
advantages the selenium web driver
does not use an additional server then
secondly
it makes direct calls to your browser
using your browser's native support
automation
so since there is no intermediate server
there the browser is controlled directly
from the operating system level itself
now due to this direct communication
the overall the trips what we saw from
the rc server to the browser and from
the browser back to the rc server and to
the test scripts right
this was an indirect communication since
this whole thing was avoided the speed
of test execution
is much faster in rc and this overall
architecture of
the web driver if you see it is much
much simpler than what the rc provides
so this was the major drawback from the
rc
and this is where webdriver replaced rc
now was that all because of the
architecture
no there were few other shortcomings
with the rc api is in selenium rc a
single function has several commands
redundant and confusing api rc is less
object oriented api though there are
good set of apis to work with
they are pretty redundant and confusing
for example
how and when to use a type key or a type
command
another example is the mouse commands
click or to use
click at or when to use mouse at or
mouse tab so this was getting pretty
confusing for the developers and to top
it all this
every browser interprets the command
differently which makes your test cases
brittle
when it has to work on the multiple
browsers developers had a tough time
making their scripts cross browser and
they had to add browser specific code
whereas selenium driver comes with a set
of more matured and simpler api
which are pretty straight forward to use
for example
a simple click to simulate a click
action on any web element send keys
which simply means
send the text to any web element on your
web page scroll up or down on the web
page and so on so we will see more of
this commands when we actually start
working with the
web driver another difference is the
browser support
though both rc and webdriver supports
multiple browser
rc does not have support for html unit
which is a headless browser whereas
the web driver supports testing on
headless browser now what is the
settlers browser headless browser is a
browser which does not have a ui
it makes testing much faster because it
does not need a real browser
for testing now to summarize all this so
if you look at the rc and the web driver
comparison which we talked about
rc is a complex architecture whereas
webdriver has a simple architecture
for the main reason that webdriver
removed the need of having an
intermediate server rc
the execution of your test cases or your
automation scripts it's much slower than
the
web driver rca requires a rc server to
interact with the browser
whereas the selenium web driver
interacts with the browser directly
using the web drivers also we saw the
apis which rc provides which are pretty
confusing
and web drivers we have much easier and
easy to use
apis no support for html unit browser
which is a headlight
browser selenium driver also provides
support for
html unit browser now that we have
understood what selenium rc is and why
webdriver replaced rc
let's go another level deeper into
webdriver so what is selenium webdriver
we know that the webdriver in its
simplest term
is a tool or a programming interface
to create and execute test cases on a
web application
it supports multiple browsers ie firefox
chrome opera safari edge and it also has
support for headless browser so we will
know in some time what
is in headless browser some of the
features of webdriver
so while rc was introduced in 2004
webdriver got
introduced by simon stewart in 2006.
driver can run on any platform of your
choice linux
windows mac and even if you have a
ubuntu machine you can
run your selenium web drive and what is
this actual web driver is it an ide
no it is a simply and programming
interface to run your test
cases and how does it work the test
cases are created
and executed using web elements or the
objects
using web locators and webdriver methods
so once we get into the demo or once you
start understanding how selenium works
you will
understand what are these webdriver
methods and the locating techniques
which are used to perform these actions
on web element selenium webdriver is
pretty fast
why since the webdriver interacts
directly with the browser
and does not have an intermediate server
like rc
each browser with which you want to work
with has its own driver
on which your application runs and this
driver is responsible to make the
browser
understand the command which are being
passed from your script
like a click of button or entering some
text in any of the
input fields through your scripts you
tell which browser you want to work with
say you want to do all this action say
on the chrome browser if you want to
work with chrome
browser then the chrome driver is
responsible for
interpreting your instructions from your
test case and executing them on the web
application which is
launched on chrome browser earlier so
like rc webdriver
also supports multi-programming
languages in which
you can write your test scripts like the
ones which are listed here
also web driver supports different
frameworks like test ng
junit and n unit when we talk about the
limitations of webdriver
you will appreciate how this support for
various frameworks and tools
help in making the selenium a complete
automation solution for web application
now let's try to know what is the
architecture of
selenium webdriver webdriver has four
different components in it
one we have the client libraries or what
is also called as
language binding since i said selenium
supports multiple languages and you are
free to use any of the supported
languages to create your automation
script there are libraries available on
selenium website which you
need to download and use them so
selenium provides lot of apis for us to
interact with the browsers and when we
do the demo i will be showing some of
those apis now what are these abs these
apis are the rest apis
rest is representational stateful aps
and
everything for selenium happens to this
rest calls
the second component is the json wire
protocol so what is json
javascript object notation and it's a
standard for exchanging data over the
web so for example you want to launch a
web application through your script so
what selenium does is
it creates a json payload and post the
request
to the browser driver right and where
are this browser driver
these are here right and what are these
browser drivers these are a driver
specific to each browser so if you see
here you can see drivers for chrome
firefox
opera safari and edge right so we
interact with the actual browsers here
using these drivers and how does this
happen
this driver establishes connection with
the real browser
without revealing the internal logic of
browser functionality right that's
exactly the function of this browser
driver
now what does that mean let's say we
want to execute a test script so what
happens when the script is executed is
an http request is generated and sent to
browser driver for each command in the
script
and then the driver receives the request
through this http server
and does all the execution on the actual
browser
once the execution is done the execution
results are just sent
back over the same http server to your
test scripts
so this is the simplest form of the
architecture
of the selenium webdriver well now as
every tool has its own advantages and
its limitations so let's look at
what selenium limited webdriver
limitations are cannot test mobile
applications requires framework like
apm selenium is for automatic web
application
it cannot handle mobile right mobile
applications are different and they have
its own set of automation tools however
what selenium provides is the support
for integrating this apm tool apm tool
is one of
the popular tools for mobile application
automation right so it provides a
support for integrating apm tools
so using apm and selenium you can still
achieve mobile application automation
now when do you usually use this
in cases where say your application
under test is also supported on mobile
devices
so that means you need a mechanism to
run your test cases on your web browser
as well as your mobile browsers right
and this is how you achieve it using
selenium
when we talked about components of
selenium i said that the web driver can
achieve only sequential execution
but in real time we know that we just
cannot live with this
we need to have a parallel execution on
multiple machines and on multiple
process
so this limitation of webdriver is
replaced by having the grid which helps
us in achieve the parallel execution and
do check out our video
on more details on selenium grid
selenium webdriver has
limited reporting capability it can help
create basic reports
but definitely we need more especially
when we are working on a big project
we need good reports to be created so
what it does is we have
a support for multiple tools like test
ng report ng and even
the extent reports which you can
integrate with selenium and generate
beautiful reports
isn't it really powerful all right
there's another challenge what we have
these are amongst few of the challenges
what i have put across here
there are other challenges also but
always there is a workaround to get
through this challenge so another
challenge which we have mentioned here
is selenium is not very good with image
testing
especially designed for web application
automation
but then we have other tools which can
be used along with selenium to achieve
any kind of image testing you want to do
like auto it and securely so same way
the way it provides a mechanism to
integrate apm
so selenium also provides a way for
integrating autoit and the security
tools
so if you look at all this selenium
still provides a complete solution for
our automation need and that's the
beauty of selenium that makes it most
powerful tool today for
automation okay so let's look at
webdriver in action
so before we do that let's understand
some of the basic browser commands and
functions that we will be using in our
demo today the get commands so there are
six get commands to perform various
actions on the browser
driver.get this is used to launch any
website application it takes a string
argument and this needs to be a fully
formed url which you want to
launch driver.gettitle so this method
fetches
the title of the web page which you're
working with so for example
let's go to ebay so if you just hover
your mouse here
can you see the text there electronics
cars fashion collectibles coupons and
more
ebay so this is nothing but title of
this current page
and this command helps us to get the
title
get current url so to get the url of any
page is when you want to use this
command
so this will be used especially when
you're working with multiple web pages
and you want to
say print whatever the current url
you're working on on the console
get page source this method dumps the
complete html page source
on your console actually this is not
really much used
uh unless you really need to look at
anything in your
html pages and then there are two more
get commands related to windows handles
these are used for handling multiple
tabs and multiple windows on the browser
now we will not be dealing with this in
today's demo however if you want to know
the details of this command these are
available in our video tutorials for
this commands
the next set of commands are the
navigational commands so these are
self-explanatory and basically
are used to navigate between the
multiple pages of your web application
the first one the driver.navigate.2 is
very similar to driver.get so both does
the
same function and then you have navigate
dot back navidad
got forward and navigate dot refresh so
this is used for refreshing your
browser page and then there are two
commands browser commands which we use
one is the driver.close so this closes
the current browser window so if you
have got multiple tabs opened in the
window and you want to close a
particular tab so that is when you use
driver.close and driver.quit what it
does it quits the
entire browser session then there are
few other commands
and these some of the commands are
listed here however if you see there's a
huge list of commands available in
selenium and since we'll be using just a
few of them in today's demo i have
listed here so let's just understand
these
very basic commands which we will be
using driver dot find element
now when you want to work with any
application what is that you need to do
you need to perform actions on the
elements of the web page and these are
called as
web elements for example let's go to our
ebay dot in so on this website say you
want to search for
jbl speakers and what do you do when you
want to search for this
you would identify the search box and
you will enter the text
jbl speakers right and then you go ahead
and click on the search button so this
is the set of operations which you will
do
now for us to write this and this is
exactly what you need to do through your
commands
for us to really write this text as jbl
speakers i need to know what this
particular element is
okay so this particular input box is my
web element which i need to identify
similarly if i want to click on the
search button i need to identify
what this button is and that's exactly
is done
by using driver.find element selenium
has
multiple ways of finding these elements
it has eight element locating techniques
and our future videos on selenium do
cover these eight element
locating techniques very much in detail
so for us right now we will be using
couple of them so one is with id
and one is with a link text the next one
the send
keys so as the name indicates it is used
to send
a certain text to any web element you
have identified or you want to work with
like in this example
as i said since we want to search for
jbl speakers right i would be basically
sending the text
jbl speakers to this web element using
send keys click so after entering the
text
what we need to do i said we need to
click on the search button so for
all such actions we have methods defined
in selenium and one of them is this
click
what this does is it just clicks on the
web element or the button which we want
to
work with so now with these basic
commands let's go ahead and
start writing our code for our test case
so what is the test case we are going to
write today
so this is my use case today so use case
one as a user
i want to log into ebay application
search for jbl speakers
and then i want to check the today's
team so there is something called as the
days deal
we will go and click on that and see
what are the deals available i have
another use case here
what says is from this website from
wherever we are
right navigate to the simply learn
website and navigate back to the ebay.
so this
using this use case 2 what i want to
show you is how do we use the
navigational commands
and my third use cases from the ebay.in
i want to print the page title
and close the browser so with this we
are trying to demonstrate at least few
commands from each of the categories
which we talked about so i will be using
eclipse for writing
our test scripts and if you want to know
how to get started with selenium how do
we install selenium you can refer to our
videos on installation of selenium by
simply done
okay let me go to my eclipse so in
eclipse what i have done is i have
already created a project called
selenium demo and in this project i have
gone ahead and created a java class in
which we will be writing our test case
so the java class which i have created
is ebay search dot java and also what i
have done is if you look at
few import statements here i have
imported all the required selenium
jars here so if you look here in the
referenced libraries
the way after we you work with java here
right so
java is the prereq for your eclipse so
you already have the java libraries
available here so what i need to do is i
also need to
import the selenium jar phase and this
is the list of selenium jar packs which
you will need to work with the selling
and this i've already imported for you
then another thing what i
do as a following a best practice is
instead of
writing all my code under this main
function here
what i do is i create methods for each
of the use case or the test case which i
am writing so same thing i am going to
do that today for all the use cases
which we have
taken for this demo now let's get
started so what is the first thing which
we need to do
the first thing what we need to do is
you need to declare your
web driver so which i've already done
here i've said web driver driver
and then i need to launch the browser
before even i go into ebay
dot in and start performing the other
testing now for me to launch browser
this is one method which i've already
written here so let me walk you through
this so there are multiple steps we need
to follow
for launching the browser the first
thing is set system property so let's
understand
this particular command here the one
which i have highlighted so this is used
to set the property for your gecko
driver
now what is a gecko driver if you
remember while we are talking of
webdriver architecture
i said for whichever browser you want to
work with you need to
tell the web driver as which browser is
what you're going to test with and in my
case here i'm going to be using firefox
browser
and also if you remember while
explaining the architecture i said every
browser
every browser has its own driver which
you need to download and install
and where is this driver let's go ahead
and see that on the selenium hq dot org
so let me go to my chrome browser i
already have a selenium hq dot org
website open here now on this website
in the download section if you go down
you can see something called as third
party drivers binding
and plugins and here you would see a
list of all browsers
gecko driver chrome opera edge right and
html unit which is headless browser so
all these browsers which selenium
supports listed
and for each of this browser we have a
driver associated with it which we can
download so if i want a gecko driver
what i need to do is i need to click on
this latest link
this will take me to the latest web
driver which is available
so depending on the operating system
which you're using right now i'm using a
mac so i've already downloaded it so
once you download you need to place it
in a particular directory okay so let us
go back to this and now if you see this
path here
what i am highlighting this is where i
have kept my gecko driver
so this gecko driver what you see is my
executable so if you are using using a
windows machine it will be
geckodriver.exe so this is the driver
which should be working with now coming
back to the system.set property
this particular method or this
particular command is used to set your
driver property it is a key value pair
and you will need to know which keys
depending on the which browsers you are
working with since i am working on
the firefox browser the key which i need
to set is the
webdriver gecko.driver if i am using
chrome
what i simply do is i have a key called
chrome and then
i would set this path to chrome driver
and this is exactly you need to do so
for you to even before launch the
browser you need to do this
set property so let me change this back
to gecko so now we are clear till here
now what is the next command which we
need to after setting the property
is after setting the property you have
to instantiate the web driver
which is done by using this particular
command driver is equal to
new firefox driver so once you do this
your browser is going to get launched
then once your browser is launched what
is the next step you do you would be
launching the application
on which you want to perform your test
and that is done by using the command
which we just saw now driver dot get now
since i'm going to be working with
ebay.i have just said
dot get and the url fully formed url so
this particular method
is going to help me launch the firefox
browser and also launch the ebay
application
now advantage of using methods like this
is you can reuse this methods in every
test case which you are going to write
or you can make a common function of
this and just call this function
in any of your test cases now for me to
call this method what am i going to do
i am going to create an object of this
class let's do that
object is equal to new done and then i
need to call this
method obj dot launch browser good so
far
all right so now let's get to the first
use case so let's go back to our
presentation and see what was our first
use case our first use case was that we
want to launch the ebay
application which we have already done
in the launch browser method
and then we want to search for jbl
speakers
now for that what we will do let me
create a method here
so i will call this method i'll say
public void
say search product that's my method name
so i have created a method called search
product now what i need to do is
i need to search for jbl speaker so for
that let me go to my firefox browser and
i need to first identify the search box
element
so for identifying what i do i go to
this website i go to this element
and then i say inspect element so now i
know
that there is already an id which is
unique to this particular web element
available so i'm going to make use of
this id
i need to go to my eclipse so now here
i'm going to use the find element method
so for that i'll say driver dot find
element
i'll say by dot id and it's a string
argument i'll just copy
the id which i copied from the firefox
browser and then what is the operation i
need to do here
i need to send keys and what is the keys
i need to send
the product which i am searching for i
am searching for
say jbl speakers done so with this
command what it will do is it will enter
the text jbl speakers in the search box
after doing this i need to click on the
search button now similarly i need to
identify
what is the web element search for this
again i already have a unique id here
which i'm just going to simply copy from
here and use it in the
find elements so same thing i will do
driver dot find element
by dot id and this is the id of the
button and here what is my operation i
need to
click done good so far now other thing
what we also need to
understand here is so what happens
sometimes depending on the website
some websites are pretty slow even by
loading the page and some are pretty
fast
now for the selenium to work without
having to fail or without having to
create
exception of not finding the elements it
is good to use
certain weights so while we need to use
weights say for example
when after entering the jbl speakers and
after clicking the button it's going to
take a while
for it to search for jbl speakers and
give us that webpage with the list of
jpm speakers and even before we start
doing the first command like searching
once we
load the page it takes time for the
complete page to get loaded
okay so selenium provides lot of
synchronization commands right and it's
a very big topic on its own
which needs to be used especially when
you're working with any kind of website
okay so there is a since it's a separate
topic there's a separate video which
will help you understand how to use the
synchronization
now for the demo purpose we have certain
weight commands which can be used and
that is exactly which i am going to use
here
so that is called as thread dot so what
this
does is say i'm going to give 2000 here
what this does is this basically this
script
waits for two second right after the
previous command is executed
and then it executes your next command
which is our find element
now this is showing us an exception
because it wants us to add a
exception here at throws declaration
which is interrupted exception okay we
need to do this
so once we are done okay we have done
the click so let's see what is the first
use case which we had have we
covered everything in the first use case
okay we said login to ebay done search
for jbl speakers and then i want to
check on the
days d we need to do this also so for
that again what we need to do is we need
to go and identify
so what i will do i'll use the inspector
here and look for this daily deals
now this is a link text it's an anchor
tag so what i will do i'll copy this
link text
daily deals i'll go to my eclipse
now after this i will give another
thread dot sleep of say two seconds
that should be more than enough and then
i'll say driver dot
find element now this time i will be
using
something called as link text and here
as an argument as a parameter am going
to paste the daily deals which i just
copied and then what do i need to do on
this web element i just need to do a
click operation
done so the complete first use case we
have covered so what we will do is let's
go ahead
and execute this first use case now i
have launched the browser here i also
need to call this method
which is search product now again here
since we are
doing that add through declaration on
the method we also need to do it for the
main function exception added i'll save
this and for me to run this what i
do is i simply right click on that and i
say run as
java application now we see that our
firefox browser is launched
the ebay application is also launched
and
jbl speakers entered and search clicked
so we have a list of jbl speakers here
and now as per our test case it has to
go on the daily days which it just did
great all right so we have our first use
case working so right now i have not
used the browser.close so what i will do
is
i'll just manually go and close this
process so we are done with our first
use case
now let's move to our second use case so
what second use case says is from
wherever you are
right now we are on the ebay dot in
navigate to simply learn website
and then navigate back to ebay. so let's
see how to
handle that so let's go back to my
eclipse here now let's create another
method
instead of saying test case 2 or use
case 2 we'll give a more meaningful name
i'll say navigate since we are
exercising the navigates command
navigate commands here i'll just use
this method
now so we have done the click so i need
a quick thread dot sleep here because i
want
it to wait so that we can see otherwise
it's going to be so fast we will not be
able to see
what are the operations it did so i'll
just add a thread dot slip before we
start navigating to the new website okay
thread dot
sleep and i guess two seconds should be
good enough even here
so same thing we need to add the
exception so add throws declaration
and interrupted exception all right done
so now what we need to do is we need to
navigate to the simplylearn.com so for
that first i need a fully formed url
of the website which i want to launch
okay so let me go to
and here instead of ebay.in i would say
let's search for
simply learn i have it here and i just
pick this from here
https www.simplylearn.com so let me go
to my eclipse
and here we saw another command like get
we said
navigate dot 2. so let's use the same
command so i'll say driver
dot navigate dot 2 and i'm going to use
two url
because or you can just use a string
because this is going to be a string
variable now what does this command do
this will simply navigate to the url
which we have specified here
now here again i'm going to give a quick
sleep here so that
we we are able to see that website
before we navigate back to the
ebay. so i'll use a thread.sleep this
time probably i'll give a three second
wait then what does our use case say
let's go back to use case once and check
and it says and navigate back to ebay
dot it so that means i need to use a
driver dot
navigate dot can you see the list of
commands here which
provide for which the navigate class
provides okay and the back is what we
need to use so that it comes back to the
ebay dot done so far so good now let's
do one thing before even we go to the
use case three let's
execute our test case still here so what
i'll do i'll save this program
and after search product i will call
navigate
method okay i will save this and then
right click run as java application so
our firefox is getting launched it has
launched
the ebay application is on so it's going
to first find the jbl speakers
click on the search we have a list of
jbl speakers
then it will click on the daily deals
yes it is doing that
we got the deals of the day yes it is
now navigating to simplylearn.com now
after three seconds
it should take me back to the ebay. okay
cool so this was the last
page where we left before we navigated
to simply
right and that is where we have come
back using the back command so now
let me close this again because i have
still not incorporated the driver.close
now let us look at the use case 3. now
use case 3 says once you're back to
ebay.n
print the page title and then close the
browser cool very simple so we'll go
back to eclipse
probably in the same method what i can
do is once i'm back here i will say
so i have to use driver dot get title
that was a spelling mistake
driver dot get title okay this is the
method which we are going to use
to get the title of the page now we also
said that once we get the page title we
want to print it
on the console now how do you print it
on console you just use a sys out
statement
so instead of just writing this what i
will do is i'll directly write
a sysout statement system.out.println
and i'll write a text as the title of
this page is
and then we will concatenate with driver
dot
get title as simple as that and after i
do this
i will simply call it's actually i want
to call the driver.list but
it's always good to create a separate
method so i'll
say public void close browser method and
here
i'll simply say driver dot quit you can
use close or you can use quick so let me
demonstrate how do we use quit here
now i need to call the close browser so
simply what i'll do i'll say obj dot
close browser method okay so this
completes our all three use cases so now
let's
execute all these three use cases and we
should be able to see the title of this
page
on the console so same thing what i do
is right click
run as java application okay same thing
our
ebay is launched now send keys the jbl
speakers click on search button
executed and then it has to click on the
daily deals
that it has done moves to simply learn
website
now it has to come back to ebay.n and we
should be able to see the close process
which just happened at the snap of the
finger right now for us to know whether
it really happened
what we have done is we have printed the
page title okay now can you see here
we have the complete page title printed
here all right
so let's go back so let's look at what
are the key takeaways from that
so in this overall video we saw what was
selenium
what is selenium webdriver what was the
limitation of the remote control which
is selenium rc
how did webdriver replaced it and we
went into learning the architecture of
the
selenium web travel which is very
important for us to understand because
we will be working with the web driver
to create all our automation scripts and
then as i said every tool has its own
limitation we also talked about
limitations at a very high level and
also as there are workarounds
and then i also demo some of the browser
apis and the usages
and some of the methods which we use
with selling it okay so
that brings us to the end of this video
and i hope you all
enjoyed watching this video do check out
our other videos on selenium
webdriver from simplyla thank you very
much and have a good day
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
turn it up and get certified
click here